so you can perfect
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to the
dope as usual podcast
we are here to talk about life problems
accomplishments drugs
and everything in between today today
i'm
super excited we have a special guest
for you guys comedian
host of the honeydew podcast very
[ __ ] awesome ryan sickler
thank you so much thank you for having
me thank you for coming today i
appreciate it
guys i want to get right into this i
have uh i did my homework
i got a list
[Music]
i can't wait there we go i'm gonna start
i'm gonna start it off with the basics
though
just some random stuff uh the basics for
everyone that doesn't know who ryan
zickler is here we go
i know you're born in baltimore raised
in baltimore correct born in west
baltimore lived there for a little while
raised in
carroll county how far is that uh like
25 minutes
baltimore yeah basically i say baltimore
but i mean all of my family was there so
i spent that's where i got my
street education that's what i was going
to ask you how was it growing up and
because all baltimore i know is the wire
that's all i know about and the ravens
yeah that's all anyone really knows
edgar allan poe you throw in there the
orioles um
how was growing up it was different it
was not like that like
the harbor and all that area back then
was not great
they did this whole program where you
could buy a home for a dollar
in baltimore you could buy a row home
for a buck the only
catch was you had to get it legally up
to code so
you didn't have to trick it out you have
to do anything but you had to have your
electricity so maybe you're putting 20
25 grand in this home but there were
people who could afford it and they
bought
blocks of that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
this like mcdonald's
nice and then gentrified and push those
people out
so then the areas around what they call
camden yards now which never
well existed it didn't exist as stadiums
it was train yards and [ __ ] like that
now those areas are nice and there's a
little bit of scratch all right nice
like [ __ ] the art district down here
just be full of bombs and crack heads
yes and now it's just baristas
and bars so it was i got a a
good school uh pretty decent school
education i mean
on me how i finished uh out in the
county and the city is where i got the
street education where my cousins lived
there we spent
a lot of time you're a good kid or
you're running the [ __ ] streets
no no i was a good kid uh i didn't run
the streets but
um nah um so i assume
um it's safe to say you weren't doing a
bunch of drugs in high school
no so my life took a a different turn
my mom bailed on the family earlier
didn't want to be part of it we're with
our dad raised being raised by a single
dad
he dies when we're 16. um
and after that there was no need to run
the streets because we were the house
where there were no parents and no
parental supervision so everyone came
next
question you guys are on your own after
you have some outsider [ __ ] yes
really absolutely yeah every day so our
dad was everything to us
and we're living with him he has a heart
attack
um thanksgiving weekend we spend the
weekend down at my aunts in baltimore
because he was at hopkins which is
johns hopkins the world renown hospital
where people go to die also
and um he gets out a few days later
we have the monday off from school he
goes to bed that sunday night
and doesn't wake up dies in his bed um
we find him in the morning in his bed
you guys found him yeah my younger
brother did and came and got us and
we're 16 at the time
officially he's 12. when they bury my
dad a few days later they decide to do
it on his 13th birthday so
yo what [ __ ] movie is this man oh my
god we had a wake
and a birthday party did you just do the
birthday party yeah we're out there
crying and then switching gears
i
he's not even in the ground yet yeah you
know what i'm glad that you can laugh
about that
that was [ __ ] up
in the family at the time but uh so
after that our mother we're forced we
have
we have a choice i shouldn't say we're
forced we have a choice we're minors
so we have the opportunity to live with
our next of kim which is our mom
none of your 18 no 16 i have a twin
brother 16 16 and now 13 officially on
his birthday barry
um and or we can go live with our
grandmother who lives
literally right outside the city she's
cool she was awesome my grandmother
italian grandma no because
the only thing we have are our friends
we have
no one we're living by ourselves we have
known we're playing
sports we stayed for your friends if we
go to a new school we know no one now we
have
no one to talk to no one to relate to no
one knows the story no one knows
anything the parents we
that that are kind to us and good to us
don't live in the area you know so we
chose ourselves really
and um we move in with our mom
and this uh and you have no relationship
with your mom at all
she hated me what the [ __ ] we just
recently connect reconnected and things
are going well but
forever um no she has
openly said went to court i mean boy
i'll tell you all of it so you're asking
questions i'll tell you
my mom never had an issue with drugs or
alcohol
oh that was my next question just
decided it's a logical question we've
talked about all this just decided
i don't want to be with my family i'd
rather be with my
was she friends the time when you were a
kid she left
she had to be in her 20s yeah when she
had us in her probably
mid to late twenties she's an adult yeah
she was an adult
she left in her 30s we were like fifth
grade
kramer versus kramer so jesus christ
so um we're with our dad
and he dies and
now we're gonna move into this apartment
with her my mom had
gone to court with my dad for custody
and
the judge was a woman this is 1989
that's how long otis is and
the judge says to my father you know
what what would you like and he said
well i'd like my kids
i love my kids i want all of my kids i
want all three of them
but if you're just gonna give her
custody because she's the mom
then i think the best thing to do is for
the
three of them to be together i don't
want to split these kids up like just
because
we have [ __ ] problems and [ __ ] so the
judge was like okay and then she asked
my mom
and my older brother older he's four
minutes older uh we're fraternal twins
but he uh
his name's derek and my younger
brother's todd i'm assuming it's a twin
situation you got the [ __ ] jeans like
danny devito
i feel like he's john my mom is [ __ ]
six feet tall she's taller than me yeah
everybody i'm the shortest person six
one and six two i'm the shortest person
in the family
my other uncles are six six on my
grandma's side yeah i got the [ __ ]
you two got the dandy beetlejuice so um
she tells the judge i want todd the
youngest
derek can come if he wants but i do not
want ryan
and the judge said this about you and
you had to hear that [ __ ]
no i didn't go to court because i i she
had told me my whole life
i knew oh you're most happy to say yeah
yeah i i knew what she was gonna say so
i didn't need to go to court i actually
went to the relationship for the weekend
um so um this is this is
all her uh you know you're a child
you got no say anything before um and i
asked her about it and she just can't
all she can say is i don't know so
that comes with a lot of not working on
yourself too you know and really finding
out but
it is what it is so um
[Music]
the judge is so bothered by this and
disturb us she said in all my years
of dealing with family i've never heard
a mother
say i don't want a child exactly it
sounds like a [ __ ] movie that's
that's what i'm saying
so she gave my dad in 1989 full custody
and made my mom pay him child support
and set a [ __ ] example yeah
that's a win i'm sorry that's you don't
hear that 2021. you don't hear that
today
this was 1989. that woman was so [ __ ]
bothered by that
she was like okay well then you're
paying that's [ __ ] great
at least looked out for the kids yes the
strangers well your dad sounded like he
was the [ __ ] man because
he was talking about pan am boston
really yes and that's dc
pretty much so we lived up in maryland
so he's commuting back then with
no cell phones or pagers or any of that
[ __ ] if you wanted to get a hold of
somebody you had to call when they were
you know
near the wall other day too like how you
know your friends at home you [ __ ]
knock on the door and that's their
parents their kids are home it's
yeah back then especially yeah you don't
know i i do leave my bike on the grass
run up yeah look back six times unless
it gets stolen he's not here all right
get back on my bike
that was my whole life that was what you
did back in the day you knocked on
somebody's
you had to have a personality you had to
know how to talk to people you know
so anyway we decide after my father dies
that we're gonna live with our mother in
this two bedroom apartment
so my two brothers and i basically
shack up in this one bedroom they're in
bunk beds and i'm in a twin bed right
next to them
um and this is 10th 11th and 12th grade
this is our whole high school
and she's never home she has a boyfriend
who lives a few miles away
and that's it she stays with him monday
to sunday she comes home on sunday
rent the house and a few hours she's
there to do laundry grab a few things
pack a bag and boom out
we don't see her which is in hindsight
it's better for you it is absolutely
better the other way would have been so
much worse
i totally understand i went through some
[ __ ] like that um she was very abusive
you know it that [ __ ] stopped once we
got older and could fight back
[ __ ] out of you yeah that punched me in
the face yeah you told me your mom was a
gangster and i went that's it yeah
yeah [ __ ] really wow that sounds like a
[ __ ]
horrible yes so we raised ourselves got
ourselves to school
every single day uh graduated good guy
had a 3.0
but but sports is what saved me i
wouldn't have gone to school
you couldn't play sports you didn't
weren't in school
i played in high school i played soccer
i played
my freshman year i played soccer
basketball baseball in the same year
yeah and then my sophomore year was
soccer wrestling the
cross lacrosse so i played all those i
always imagined would be like to go to
school that has lacrosse
a great [ __ ] sport rugby is a real
man's i cannot
yes you are i've seen some of those
videos yeah no americans
we got it made over 100 million
contracts and helmets yeah
um so yeah that's the formative years
now we're 16 17
18. um on our own
growing up going to school signing each
other's permission slips
our little brother gets there we're
raising each other
um and we and back to running streets so
there was no need to run the street you
were running
out of home where everyone came and you
know it doesn't matter how you were that
house
we were that house people straight up
there's no parents in here at all right
now
like no but we were really liked
by a lot of our friends parents and
looking back on it i'm still friends
with so many of these guys and i asked
them because their dad's like would you
let your kids stay i'm like [ __ ] no me
either
nope but these parents felt sorry for us
and their rule was
if you don't show up at school if your
grades slip
it's over so we made sure that we
worked as hard as we played because
there would be no political
college students if we didn't do it
that's exactly what i'm here you guys
are
working college students living on your
own yes joe you grew up fast
very fast yeah i was on my own at 17 i
think yeah yeah and i feel like
it stunted me by 10 years
in certain aspects of my life there are
things like financially i didn't know
anything about money except for spend
and save
yeah trying to grow investing i didn't
know
i just learned you know i'm just
learning 40 [ __ ] seven i didn't know
anything about how to let your money
make you money you know any of these
things like
um so this should show you in school
not [ __ ] tell school's a joke yeah
they didn't teach me
hustle is what i learned early and then
i had to learn
you know the work ethic and the hustle
and the mentality is what i gained first
and then i had to apply it to all the
[ __ ] that i'm still learning about now
because
i didn't have parents i finally had
google thank god for google
thank you i learned how a [ __ ] tie on
youtube i didn't need a dad
really yeah i wouldn't be able to do
that [ __ ] double wins or cadillac and
knots
no um i wore a clip-on my whole life do
you [ __ ] yeah
i'll help you every picture you ever see
oh man all the youtubers do watch one
it's so easy
for someone that does youtube a lot i
don't watch a lot of youtube yeah i
watch
ignorant [ __ ] like fights and people
freaking out and then i get off and go
back to what i was doing
i don't want to spend a lot of time on
youtube learning which i probably should
um so i wanted to bring something up to
you
okay because the first time i ever met
you was the first podcast i ever did it
was a guess
yeah thank you by the way i didn't
realize that it was also the first
podcast
and we talked about this very show you
getting it up and going at the time dude
how long ago it was yeah yeah i know it
takes a while so [ __ ] long
uh the thing i wanted to bring up to you
because the second i left and called
marty the first thing i bring up is
does does ryan know how much kenny
powers he looks like do you
know how you are the [ __ ] real life
essence
the second i talked to you went so this
is kenny powers i'm gonna be
interviewing listen
i don't know if danny mcbride watches
but i am dying to do
any project with you mcbride i could be
your cousin
right there i got it when he came out
with eastbound and down
that's when i got it a ton oh you've
heard me many times oh yeah bro
i wasn't sure i wasn't sure i also used
to rock just a goatee for the
longest time there's a picture of you on
google if you can find it marty please
there's a picture of you on google
with your sideways shot you have short
ass hair it's just it's kenny powers
the second i saw i go i did yeah i've
gotten it a bunch
i [ __ ] love that one right there that
one in the blue yeah
pan am jack far left that's the one yeah
one picture right there
no go back uh the one right next to the
podcast
third second row third stop right there
and go yeah boom that
that [ __ ] picture are you kidding me
you're like about to strike somebody out
right there
i just remember thinking yo i finally
found somebody that talks like hey
yeah man that's i've gotten out a bunch
and then people say i sound southern all
the time i've been out here for so
long yeah people say it i apparently i
draw my o's and my a's
i thought you were gonna like introduce
me into some nice place that's what it
felt like man this is
i get i get matthew mcconaughey a lot i
get
people say my daughter makes fun of me
because i said hold your daughter she's
sick
oh she's ready but her mom stalks talks
you know she's like
say florida orange juice and i'm like
florida orange juice like you mean
florida orange
floral orange juice i'm like no florida
orange juice yeah i know as you said
baltimore with a d
in it yeah i heard that earlier i talked
like a
a dummy i talked like everybody you ever
heard in a movie i sound like a surfer
really well actually really yeah you
could be the next thomas the tank engine
bro
hey nice that would be cool george
carlin did it ringo starr did it alec
baldwin did it why can't you
i don't know you enunciate well my
friend thank you for a mexican guy that
doesn't speak any spanish no spanish
thoughts managed by a white supremacist
do you [ __ ] do pretty good
we haven't gotten into that here yet oh
yeah
you got that we have it no you're good
you're good i i was thinking about the
other day
i was it was uh i was thinking about
that i found a picture of him my mom
threw him all the way and got divorced
found a picture of him in the background
really and it's him and i'm like yeah
ned flanders looks like ned flanders
nice ass dude and he's just [ __ ]
ripped underneath that was him
glasses and everything yeah i found a
picture of him the other day
it was me and my uncle wrestling and
he's in the background staring at us
[ __ ] great one picture that's made
through my mom's hate
fuel rage i got it still all right it
was pretty good
so so yeah i got kenny powers a lot
especially when he was doing
eastbound and down it's amazing man yeah
that's my uh fifth favorite show
do you watch i mean we're stuck in the
house yeah
pretty much what have you been watching
well just recently
well actually last night i couldn't stop
watching it because i was
really intrigued by the story when it
happened but it's the
um uh what's the hotel downtown in la
they just did hotel
uh [ __ ] i can't i just watched the whole
thing last night this is my cove
documentary it's like a mini series and
it's about the the
canadian girl she was asian who oh
that's stuck in the
the law and the water in the water tank
yeah everybody was saying like if
something stinks
yeah people were she was in there for 19
days
or something people were drinking that
water showering
in the water with a dead body in it yeah
yeah that that right there
yeah what's the hotel called cecil hotel
that's it yeah
and it's i couldn't stop watching and i
remember like
i remember the day they shut the [ __ ]
when they found her that she was dead
and i was like oh and i followed it and
i couldn't i stayed up so late last
night watching i couldn't stop watching
the damn thing
oh i've been my girlfriend watches all
the friends i can't watch people getting
hurt
or keep getting killed it makes me
unjustly it makes me so upset
yeah like watching forensic i don't want
to watch cold case files because they
don't [ __ ] find them
i'm gonna tell you that right now they i
pissed them one night i got really high
and i was like i'm gonna watch some
colgate and then i was so into the
episode and at the end they're like if
you or anyone you're not going to go
i forgot what i was watching i forgot i
was watching a cold case like
i was like wait you don't solve this i
know the ending i know the [ __ ] end
let's work backwards from here it'll be
more fun i guess
um so like i told you earlier i got some
notes
your entire i feel like it's the story
stories behind the storytellers the
honeydew i want to hear something i want
to hear i have
a couple of questions i want to ask you
i want to hear your stories
because i know you do you you're telling
stories on your podcast but i want to
i want to hear all of it just from you
you know what i'm saying so
i want to know the day you what's the
moment you decided to be a comedian
because i know people
everybody says well people told me i was
funny no it's not what it is
it's something else i know it's
something else even though i don't know
your story
but was there a moment that you went to
bed and as you're falling asleep you're
like
all right that this is the path i'm
gonna take or was it a
phase there's certainly a moment i i
can't say it was like that though i
can't say it was like i lay down and go
and once it happened and when you're
going to sleep like okay i can tell you
the moment comedy was born
into me and after that it was my drug i
can
you know it fueled me to then decide
what because when i first got into
comedy i didn't think immediately at 10
i'm going to be a standout 10 years old
really i just thought
i love making i love this laughter thing
and i i'm
whoa i can do that with the relatives
and stuff so i was
i caught the bug of being able to be
funny early and
i really took to that so yeah i didn't
do drugs
until i drank but um so at 10 years old
um i told this story a bunch but you
know you got a different audience i'm
gonna tell you i want to hear
i've never heard it back in uh maryland
before all the [ __ ] before my mom
cheats on my dad and they get this
divorce and that's when all the [ __ ]
goes
haywire um
[Music]
we had something called super tv and it
was the early cable days and the box
ironically was was about as big as that
because for a minute cable boxes got
small
and then the dvr came on they all went
right back to the same side
yeah size excuse me so uh it was called
super tv and it was like you had this
little silver button you pressed on and
after like 6 p.m you got
hbo you got a playboy channel which back
then
the wildest [ __ ] was like naked
tic-tac-toe it was
nothing but still but still titties and
a couple other pay channels um
and i don't know why but one night i
snuck down out of my bed
and i was laying in the the um here's my
accent and people say it's a foyer but i
grew up calling it a foyer
and i'm laying in the foyer and the
living room's in front of me my dad's in
his recliner and
um i see him watching this movie and i
can see that there are kids
in the movie so i think well
i'm i'm probably allowed to watch this
[ __ ] kids are watching it
and all of a sudden it's richard pryor
and he does like just his hat catches on
fire he's
he's pushing a bus out of the mud with
the clan i don't even know what the clam
was
but i could tell it was he's like don't
talk about this they're all saying i was
like i started laughing so hard
that i got caught and my dad turned
around
and he's like get in here and i went and
i was like oh [ __ ] go sit down and i
sat down he was finished watching this
with me
and that was it oh so watching
and also i'm getting some of it because
there's there's children
you know there's kids in it so there's
some [ __ ] i'm
getting and i'm laughing at these kids
who i can tell they're [ __ ] up one
kid's blind he's driving the bus you
know i don't
10 years old you know what the [ __ ] that
is hilarious it's hilarious
you know uh one kid's a pyro and setting
everything on fire
and so seeing the reaction is what
really made you think i want to do what
they just did to him yeah i can totally
understand yeah that was the that was
when it was born
um and after that i chased the laugh
forever i'm still chasing it and and i
but i say go back to like when i
actually decided
i moved here to california in 94 right
uh i mean like a couple days after the
north ridge quake
i got up and left that day got here i
went to cal state northridge it was
delayed
by like a month because that was the
epicenter the school was destroyed
um but i stayed and went to school
through june
uh went back to maryland and then the
next semester enrollment just like it
almost i feel like it tripled
um you went to four years you went to
did you finish college i went to junior
college
community college 13th grade 13th the
14th for two years got my aaa
and finished that was my next question
was i did i always i always finished bro
i'm not one of those dudes i don't have
they're in the project car on my yard
you know what i'm saying
so i do the two years but i did the two
years because i knew
i wasn't getting into a four year
without getting these two years of good
grades the worst
so i got good grades in my two-year got
the degree
also so that all of my credits or at
least the majority of them would
transfer because if you didn't
a lot of them would fall to the wayside
you had to take theirs because that's
the whole catch and the [ __ ] of
college too
so i took the degree and i wanted to
come here to do comedy but i
was you look i've been working without a
net since i was 16.
i have no one to call and ask for
anything uh there's no one that can
financially help me
especially so i went to college to learn
uh mass comm so tv this [ __ ] really
this [ __ ] i mean it wasn't this but it
was still cameras mics
radio shows all that even though they
had that [ __ ]
yeah bro i did i was editing on real to
real
this guy would make us going on a
[ __ ] saturday like we don't
even do this anymore he's like i wanted
to know how we used to do it
we don't care i grew up learning
ms doss and lotus on computers exactly
and all of it was gone instantly but we
got tested on a grade and
like this is the way or like it is but
it ain't that so you had literally had
to
be discussed you had a sense literally i
needed to learn this because i knew i
liked
tv and movies and the the mindset behind
it so i didn't just want to be
a comedian i wanted to get into you know
hold the hole up just jump straight up
and you came to the epicenter
and um i get to cal state northridge the
school's all [ __ ] up so i go back to
maryland and i'm from the earthquake
yeah
so destroyed you're driving there's an
earthquake going on i woke up
and the school my my friend's mom i
stayed at their house the night before i
got up to go
and uh get the [ __ ] out of here she
shook me awake i thought i was having a
dream she was like ryan
ryan she's turning cnn on she's like
your school's destroyed your school's
destroyed california just had a
i'm coming out of sleep like i'm leaving
today get the [ __ ] out of here and it
was gone and i was like
oh [ __ ] on your northridge 94 on martin
luther king jr
day um there it is and um that's what it
looked like around here
right there when i got here this is what
it looked like the freeways broke well
that one was broken these are the store
fronts and apartments
um yeah and i live look up
um there's the mall right there look up
the parking garage on zelda that's where
i lived see if that thing's actually
there that might be it right there
um parking garage zelda or 1994
northridge earlier
what are the chances of that you're
about to start a new venture new life
and it literally
crumbles to the [ __ ] land this is
literally out my window
that's what i looked at every day that
was my view every day of that thing the
[ __ ] out of here
so i walk to school every day through
this rubble we're in trailers and stuff
and i'm still
i i'm still determined i go back to
maryland i have the
because what happened was i was on my
house living on my own
and i was like i'm gonna knock this out
i'm only one sk one
algebra class away from getting my aaa
right now
you gotta go get that i think i'm just
gonna do it online come on yeah of
course
this is why i'll get the a this is why
62 credits or 64. what is it i don't
know i was taking 18 credits a semester
or i was taking the 18 units you were
doing good i was doing good for a whole
year
yeah i did great i did great and then a
year and a half came i still have
nightmares
i ever have panic dreams still yeah well
no they stopped i'm older than you so
listen
dreams are just picking up but they'd
make no sense i would be
all of a sudden i've graduated i've got
the documents i've got the papers i've
got all of it i would dream
that i had missed the [ __ ] class and
it's
been taking months and holy [ __ ]
it's english and i'm running and they're
and they're doing math in there i'm like
how much did i say my name
are you [ __ ] serious and i run to the
office and go what's your class what's
going on what's going on bruno my
teachers guys
yeah yeah who are these people it's that
feeling yeah
i have the same exact dream but i also
used to dream and that
that this one went away first that one
goes away
it just started took a while mine just
started
um that's telling you you need to go get
get that goddamn thing and it'll stop
i um i would dream i'd have nightmares
early on that i had to move home for
any reason save money and afford it back
to maryland i had that dream a couple
years and
i would have the anxiety about not being
able to have a creative outlet on a
tuesday you know
go out on a monday night and do stand-up
or whatever so
um yeah i get that i totally get it
really yeah i finished up
and and then came back again um
and worked um out here in
post-production
for a long time writing promos producing
sizzle reels
i've worked with oprah i've worked for
really yeah i met oprah and worked with
her
and when she started their own network
so i've done
all that and it's all culminated into
doing it for me
i got tired of doing it for everybody i
could do this you could set that up and
set that camera up no
i'm not techy like that those are
specials that's marty
martin's special guy i didn't know
martin andy and the dobbs and all these
guys or
facetime yesterday i didn't know you
type like a [ __ ] machine it's the
first time i've ever heard you type
are you [ __ ] kidding me i'm like i i
want to have a i type good
type of you hunt and peck but i type
fast see but in
my high school back in the 90s actually
the 80s when i took this class
it was typing we learned on a typewriter
bro you know
they're gone yeah but they had caught
you to home row asdf jk i'll send you
guys
everything i got out of it i asked him i
don't like this
i'm out and i left spanish class oh
spanish class
maybe i should have stayed yeah i got
kicked out i got
we mutually agreed my teacher first day
sits down she says that the sec
in in spanish i found out later what she
said because i don't [ __ ] speak
spanish it's the first day
she says you cannot speak english in
this class stand up and say your name
and then she said in english to me
because i didn't know what the [ __ ] she
was saying and i don't know what
it's such a weird way to start class
don't speak
you don't know it yet first day don't
speak english
so i wouldn't do it because i didn't
know how to say it she kept getting mad
at me and then she yelled at me in
english
day two i told her i'm not doing it i
don't you need to give me a paper with
translations so i can speak in class
she wouldn't do it she screamed at me in
class a young pretty ass mexican teacher
which i was like hey come on give me a
[ __ ] break
i was shocked i was shocked i'm like hey
your attitude miss makes me not like you
at all
and then after class you stayed and she
said hey will you make my life easier
just leave my classical
if you would sign the paperwork i will
leave today
make my life easy that's what she said
to me and then i got uh
pals pals is the when you help
uh mentally handicapped kids and stuff
they have the class i did that from like
third night steps
he loves them there's no conflict it's
the best thing ever
wait you're happy what else you want to
make you happy what can i do for and
that's the whole
and also you puts in a lot of [ __ ] in
perspective where you're like what am i
complaining
about this kid gets something comes here
every day is happy and i'm bitching
about homework or whatever thank you i
have to walk all the way home
this guy can't walk yeah there was a guy
his name was yoshi
oh no no yo yo yoki or so i can't
remember
he was this big what he was a little
little asian kid he had a bowl cut
huge thick like all kind of like he was
a little little person no
he was 16 and he was about this big like
what three feet
not even i he was like under assignment
remember that movie simon burch i do
smaller than that smaller than that and
he had a wheelchair
and he talked like wasn't jim carrey in
that one
no insider jody foster damn it
i can't i do remember it the little boy
i told him
yeah i remember that but yeah he was
super small he had a wheelchair and he
played blitz and i played him in blitz
every day
and he was super cool but you can't
understand him because he was so small
and he had like a
squirrel voice do you know have you
tried to keep in touch with him or see
no he was a freshman oh no he was a
sophomore and i was graduating
okay so i was out as soon as i was out
of school i went to not finish college
that's what i wanted to do when you went
to a five-year university
i did it was really sad but you know i
was selling drugs and people would text
me like can i get an ounce
i'm leaving town i'm like i'm leave
class i have to pay my rent and that's
how it went
and then it got to well i got to pay my
rent it was just my excuse to get the
[ __ ] out of class
i mean look for me i could have done all
the wrong things i hated it
i should be dead i should not be here
it's a 16 year old with zero parents or
parental supervision doing all the dumb
[ __ ] we did i didn't know
i should absolutely be that's where you
got the discipline though
well i didn't want to let my father down
like it was he meant something a little
bit
or two yeah we got i got a little
brother who recently and i you know
here's the thing we say
i i forget these things you do for
people but he told me
because he was [ __ ] around in college
for a while just [ __ ] around
until he really figured out what he
wanted to do which a lot of people i
feel do and um
he said i wouldn't have gone to college
if it wasn't for you i go what are you
talking about he's like you don't
remember you drove me up there and made
me [ __ ] register and i was like yeah
that's right i did
yeah i love that sound dude you love
trades i love trains
they don't last long they go by you know
yeah
my buddy used to um live on like his
house would be like where we are next to
those train tracks and we'd stay over
his house and wait for that train to
come by and shake the [ __ ] house at
like one in the morning it was awesome
you're like [ __ ] wayne's world
right there you hit it with eggs it's
right there
no i've never done anything with trains
i scared this [ __ ] my mom told me you
get sucked underneath if you get you
guys
oh see she wasn't lying no i never went
by him but see we were like i'm saying
we were dumb you know what we used to do
we used to walk down to the train track
and we'd hop the train
and ride it only in the winter and ride
it to his house
and jump because he we would build a um
like a snow
pile so that we could jump off and be
safe
we used to just hold on and but you know
what on the train
yeah that's what i learned this these
are not going they're not the ones
hauling us they're a little freight
train
going you know you know taking its
[ __ ] time you have time to do the
one-stop shop
it's one of those things where you can
run next to it for a little bit it's
like not
terribly fast maybe it's going 25 or 30.
you ain't going to keep up with it
you can run next to it and for a while
grab and pull yourself
up and then jump off so we would do that
it would only be like uh a mile
anywhere anywhere i learned like the
homeless guys would be on the track
i didn't know any of that i didn't know
that's where the the drug is that's
where the scary
that's a wrap on that [ __ ] hell no [ __ ]
that you should just
make sure that and then against merced
that's that's what the gangbangers chill
right by the train tracks um
the question i mean a story i want to
hear maybe you have one maybe you don't
for being on the roads you haven't been
on the road for over a year right yeah
and i know you're getting are you
getting beyond that
okay just wanted to just wanted to know
i had a
question about the road from all the
shows and i know you've done a lot
has there any been any hostile um
what are they called damn i'm high
audience
have you ever had something have you
ever had an encounter with the faith
not even just a fan just someone in the
audience
i mean obviously they're not going to be
heckling you but i've seen a few things
um
anything to you or to where you thought
[ __ ] maybe i should get in shape with
this
no i don't i've never had anybody like
get on now i was at a show
uh this was new year's eve which by the
way new year's eve
eve always blows new year's eve away new
year's eve eve
oh in comedy no just in life the 30th is
way better than new year what new year's
eve is what it's all about
there's no pressure to look good there's
no pressure to
impress anybody there's no parties to be
getting ready for nowhere to run late
the reservations for dinner and [ __ ] are
available
the price is not crazy and it's one day
away it's a really good way to put it
back that's every other day of the year
yeah so new year's eve right is better
than new year's eve
but in comedy it would always be this
show that would be end up being weird
and one night
uh we're at the irvine improv the old
irvine improv
and this [ __ ] drunk lady jay larsen's
now up on stage and
he had a video of it somewhere and she's
talking mad [ __ ] and he's talking
back and this [ __ ] charges the stage
and it's
you know he definitely could have took
this lady you know she's probably in her
like 50s or whatever but
you get up late stage you know or 40s
but you get up on stage and that like
when you walk up
it's like a list no that's not it
it's old but uh it's it's like
someone just left the zoo cage open and
you're standing in it you know what i
mean you're vulnerable to standing there
so
uh i've only seen someone get on stage
i've seen it online like everyone else
has but in my life
i've only seen it once where someone
actually got on stage i did a gig with
sam tripoli
at um santa barbara at the college there
um
and someone threw a shoe at him from the
stage
and then when i got up they threw the
other one and there was an exit door
right next to me so i took that
[ __ ] and just
sent that [ __ ] i was like i'm i might
have some fun with it too then guys
why are you only getting to throw it um
i did see
at the ontario improv there was a
massive
massive gang banger brawl um that
spilled into the hallway but had nothing
to do with me i was just
it was i was at the show oh gotcha
performing on the show
and you know this [ __ ] like i you know i
that's
you don't see that often anyway or else
there'd be a million of these videos but
you kill somebody holy
[ __ ] somebody like that no i wanted to
ask because you know not every time
there's
there's phones out you know yeah i just
want to know some personal experience so
for not being on the road for a year how
are you i mean you're a creative person
that's what you do you're entertaining
people what
are you doing the honeydew podcast and
the patreon the honeydew with y'all have
saved me the
the you know the honeydew what you've
done if you haven't seen thomas's
episode go watch his episode it's a
great episode i'm still getting comments
on it
and um somebody the other day told me if
you [ __ ] with me i'm legit so thanks for
making me legit bro
um but you know sitting
my whole life has been trauma and
i am one of these people that will sit
and laugh about it
and i mean look man i certainly have my
moments you
you can't laugh about it unless you've
cried not all that [ __ ] yeah of course
it's at the point where it's like
yeah that happened to me right and
that's it you don't think poor me
and there's misery loves company so
sitting and sharing
trauma and trauma bonding and laughing
about it with someone that makes you
feel better about their [ __ ]
it's just the way not only me but my
family has been like that at one point
we had so many people dying we we
jokingly made up a family death pool
you know like we are doing anything to
try to take your mind off of it and
deflect and
and you know um and i
who better to talk to than comedians
because they're
the the other thing the show's done is
it's made me fall in love with comedians
again because you're looking at these
people who have suffered
you know some of the [ __ ] you hear
you're like good god what am i bitching
about i know
you know and it's a lot of that's today
what are you talking about and um
you know it's it it makes me feel better
and i think
it's a healthy way um of of therapy you
know i
i've had some college professors hit me
up and say that they've made the show
mandatory listening for their students
and i'm like really thank you man yeah
i've had people reach out and ask me to
speak now at
things about dealing with trauma in a
way um and i didn't even know this was a
thing it's just you know how
we dealt with and i knew other people
did too because i'm in the comedy world
so
homeboy over here is telling me about
his mom dying or whatever and he's
killing
me with it he's killed i'm like this is
yeah this feels like
home you know so uh but the patreon is
doing it with y'all you know it's you're
doing stories with the fans
man and their stories i i had a guy i've
talked to a girl so far
who's had two [ __ ] i talked to don't
move on
yeah don't move on you have to explain
she was born
in the womb everything doubled uterus
uh inside of her body inside of her mom
when she was being born
her organs doubled ready for this one
kidney
supposed to have i said the only thing
you needed two of them
two get the [ __ ] out i swear you talk
too uteruses she's great
this woman that used to they come on and
zoom with me and she's a young girl
younger probably i think in her 20s
yeah i'm getting a really young audience
over there
i talked to a guy who died and he came
back to life he came back
hit a truck um a crane truck hit him and
sliced his head he said like deli meat
it flopped over he went into
he died then went came back but was in a
coma for like three months
i talked to him did he hear stuff no
he's talking he said he could hear
people talking but not like angels and
[ __ ] but he could hear
people around yeah he could hear the
nurses and he but he couldn't
find the the way to and then he said
once you come out of it mentally it's
what really [ __ ] with you is that you
have to learn how to walk again and he's
like mentally you still know how
and you're yelling you're yelling at
yourself like come on trying to get that
[ __ ] leg to do what it's supposed to
do but it's not talking to the brain
oh god that's a [ __ ] nightmare um i
just talked to a guy
uh just a couple episodes ago that was a
heroin addict
and he went down to philly to buy
some weed or excuse me heroin on uh from
this guy
named gordo a puerto rican dealer named
gordo now the puerto ricans were on this
street as he says and the dominican sold
coke on this street and i said
well why'd you go here and he said
honestly it was closer it was just
closer
i wanted to get my fix i go to get my
fix all the time from gordon he said
gordo was the nicest [ __ ] guy he goes
considering being a drug dealer this guy
was nice
kind polite and he carried a big ass 44
magnum and he didn't flash around and
scare you with it
gordo's tactic was poppy look at this
pistol
look how beautiful this is and he will
play it off
spin it yeah not too scary i got to let
you know
that's right here it's here i've seen
that tactic many not like just not
pulling it up and and you know
flashing it just check this out it's
really nice and he loved that gun
so he said uh there was always the
corner junkie who would wait for you to
make your purchase and then when you
turn around and walk by
yo yo can i just get a little pinch i'm
sick i'm sick can i get a little
and they'd always be like get the [ __ ]
out of here that guy was always there
they called i forget what the [ __ ] they
called him [ __ ] feed
so the one day
the guest on the show goes to buy his
heroine and he pays gordo the money and
he turns around and as he's walking away
the junkie the the regular comes walking
by him quickly
and he hears gorda go hey [ __ ]
and he the guest thinks oh my god i just
shorted him money
yeah holy [ __ ] i hope he's not talking
to me and as he turns around to see if
gordo is now speaking to him
the junkie has grabbed the package from
gordo and starts
running toward the guest and gordo pulls
the 44 up
and blows the back of this
motherfucker's head off and he said he's
running and he said from here
it splits open and all over him
all over him bro it is teeth his mouth
that sucks that's a shitty situation man
at least he didn't get popped by
accident i said how did it not go
through him and hit you or that's a dru
that's a crackhead if he trips that
bullet goes over his head
he's trying to run and it's in europe
he's like yeah bordeaux's cool but maybe
you should take a step to the right so i
go
why the [ __ ] do you go i go how long was
it he's like four days i couldn't do
he's like i was so scared he sat in his
car with blood and guts and brains
the thing that blew me away and i knew
when i knew this wasn't [ __ ]
he said that's not [ __ ] he said snot
was on him too this guy's snot because
he said he hit him
he said in slo-mo it looks just like i'm
looking at you and then from the bridge
of the nose
it just split apart and
[Music]
and i was like what a day did you stop
doing heroin nope for
four days he got sick of [ __ ] he's an
addict so then i go so do you go to the
dominicans now
down you know over here and he goes now
i went back to gourd i go why the [ __ ]
would you go back what you should go
back to
at least americans me they're mean i go
this guy just shot someone's face
onto your [ __ ] face and different
though i told
gordo you're in your rights pop that
phone in the back of the head just
and plus he's selling heroin expect him
to have a gun to shoot you in the back
of the head with
so he said i walked up i said what a
gordo saying he goes poppy you good and
he goes
good enough and he goes what do you need
and he told him he said he gave him a
free package and he said that is the
only time and the only thing they've
ever talked about or said about it
really yeah i've talked to so many of
these young kids who one kid grew up
believing his biological father was his
biological father
until one night at a school party a high
school party a girl goes listen
that's not your dad and turns out it
wasn't
and his best friend's dad was his dad
yeah there's a lot out there so crazy
[ __ ] going on
um [ __ ] gordo pulling the drug dealer
somebody's done that to me but i don't
think it was on purpose i think they
were just
uh this guy i've never seen silencers
like in double07
he had big-ass [ __ ] pistols and they
had silencers
they're so cool i want one so bad but
they're illegal as [ __ ]
dude have you ever felt have you ever
you [ __ ] with guns at all yeah
a little bit i have yeah growing up
especially rifles and [ __ ] like that
a little bit of nine millimeters got
clocks but
but wow like the p90s those ones in
in a call of duty in the video games in
real life
it's scary to go well this will kill a
whole crowd it's not i don't like that i
don't [ __ ] with guns at all
but when i see him and i like actually
feel them it gives me like that sick
feeling yeah
do not like it's it's it's gordo yeah
like oh i can pop
ruin someone's life in one estate that
was on purpose but you know i was on
purpose
that's scary man i've only been shooting
at the gun range in the woods once
that's it man i don't care how
comfortable i am with guns
that still would freak me to [ __ ] out
i'd be like what that would [ __ ] me up
i'd be pissed bro first time aids test
first thing i'm doing is going to get an
agent i was like did it get your mouth
he said probably
sat in his car for an hour and a half
shooting up with that [ __ ]
freaking the [ __ ] out i totally
understand i mean all right
i would do two i'm surprised that heroin
is got a car when you said he sat in his
car
that's the first thing i thought you got
a car the [ __ ] yeah
so it's that the podcast thank god have
kept me
um sane and and uh you know
creative and and have that outlet not to
get out because i miss
meeting people on the on how many days
how many days on the road would you be
pretty normally i would maybe i try to
do at least
a weekend a month i never did the road a
ton but i would try to do at least a
week in a month
um sometimes too but yeah and if that's
what you're but then a lot of it
challenge shows stop yeah so while
that's how are you coping with that but
yeah the podcast the livestream
sucks you don't have any you know i'm i
don't mean to be boo-hooing or anything
no no by any means people have lost
their jobs and lives but
you know there's no cities to go it was
out yeah i i
had vancouver i've never been to
vancouver i was very excited getting
ready to go to vancouver
um so yeah that's that's the way and
then i also have a series a little web
series i'm doing that's coming out
uh called learns permit that marty
helped on as well with uh my stepson
he's uh
really yeah he needed to get um hours
for his learner's permit and he's like
will you take me driving so i just put
gopros in the car and put lobsters no
you're gonna actually teach him how to
drive he learns how to drive and then he
learns about me and i learn about him
and he learns what it was like when i
was 16 and i'm learning
there's a scene where he's like he goes
to f buildings for fighting and smoking
and i go smoking what he goes vapes i'm
like jesus
christ what a death
14 i'm 14 in 9th grade this was the last
year of it too my high school liberty
high school
they had a smoking lounge for the
students lounge a lounge
and you had to be either 18 or
get written permission from your parents
saying you could smoke and
they had a room where you could do that
it was the last year of it it was my
freshman year
and that whole corner when you went
around the hallway just
[ __ ] stunk could you imagine life did
you
do you remember people smoking in inside
airplanes
yeah man it's the east coast it's
different i remember everywhere
stopped it in restaurants i was a little
kid i saw it on the news
and my grandma was watching i thought
you could [ __ ] smoke
i'm wearing this hoodie tomorrow it
doesn't stink like smoke anymore yeah
i thought i would miss for a while i
missed the the smoke and the
you know the atmosphere and all that but
nah
no no no completely off topic i will say
this can i say that's good quickly like
i'm not a cigarette smoker
i mean maybe i puff on a cigar once a
year
i don't know if that but
weed is what i smoke um and
but i love the sh
the fresh strike of a match lighting a
cigarette
after that i don't i love the smell of
that i love the smell that match
to it to that tobacco and those
chemicals i could see rosie laughing at
me i love the smell of cigarette smoke
still
do you i used to smoke a bad pack in
half a day for about that first strike
is magic it is it's like after that
oh it's still gas my bad i love gas too
i've always loved
smoke that [ __ ]
yeah no there's something about it i
don't smoke cigarettes at all i wouldn't
smoke one right now
anymore i stopped smoking cigarettes in
one moment
i smoked like a pack a day my whole for
six times
i was it's like 110 120 in summertime
where i'm from
and i used to deliver pizza and my these
three windows
and my the motors broke so they were
stuck up yeah
and you know where you stuff stuff to
keep them up that's where i was
and i had a soda from work i was
delivering pizza and i left it in there
so it got hot
and i went to spark a cigarette take up
delivery it was hot from the steam so i
went to roll my window down and it just
went
and i heard it stop and i have a little
cigarette sparked
and i take a drink of my soda because
it's so hot but it's it's hot
and i'm boxing a hot box a cigarette and
i can't breathe and i'm
and then i just threw my pack out and i
haven't smoked since wow i felt so
disgusting like
this is disgusting and then that was it
i used to watch these guys
in college back in maryland step outside
when it's like
six degrees and power smoke cigarettes
before they went into class and i'm like
[ __ ]
don't quit just gross i mean
and just throw it out and go yeah
it's just quick that's my mom my mom
smoked cigarettes my whole life that's
just disgusting
but like i said i smoked him the first
time i ever took a puff off a cigarette
and sounds ridiculous i was four and i
was at the park across the street from
my grandma's house
my mom pulled up and said stay out of
the [ __ ] street i'm going to the i'm
going to the store
she threw a cigarette out she drove off
and waited till she hit the corner
and i picked it up because i see her do
it all the time i see your friends do it
all the time
i'm going to see what the [ __ ] this is
about obviously that was stupid
but i hit it once and i started dry
heaving and i didn't smoke again until i
was like 14.
but that was the first time i tried the
cigarette because i see my mom doing it
must be tight
mm-hmm you know yeah that's what you
think that's what you think
but no um completely off topic i had to
ask
i saw that you played sports in college
but you went to the jc you played soccer
yeah
junior college all juco oh that train
bro right on top
here it's care package coming in uh what
position do you play
um i was a defender you can look at me
i'm i'm not i've never been a runner
i've never been that gazelle kid that
can just like this [ __ ] doesn't
stop running
i used to play soccer as he kills a
power forward but i was a fat kid
i think it's just fun i don't ever i
never got tired
no i loved it well soccer too is a
position where you could run really hard
for a minute and then the ball is down
the other end of the field and you can
catch your breath again
that's true that's true i don't know i
played a baseball same thing you can
steal a bag
you could be out there for 20 more
minutes baseball's different
all the pressure's on here that's right
i played [ __ ] center field
why i was terrible i dropped every
[ __ ] thing that came i was terrible
at baseball our school [ __ ] sucked
i got hit my first up to bat i got hit
right here
and my mom [ __ ] and then she walked out
from behind the dugout where the parents
were
and i told her to stop and then she
never came to another game
but that's the first my first experience
with baseball i got pegged and headed
dropped i wanted to cry so [ __ ] bad
i was good at soccer man i uh my brother
and i both made this um
[Music]
national team so it was uh we were 16
and we went to these tryouts and it
wasn't the
what not the it was a team that was like
a development team
for team usa you were an athlete it was
called
teams usa no matter what you weren't the
kid that they picked i'll pick
you weren't last no you were never the
last no i was not really so you were
you were doing it good we were both good
we were both good and um
we went we made to end up making the
team um and got to spend a month like
that's the way my life is like
these kids are are going on sabbaticals
and they're backpacking europe and
everything my whole life
has been listen i'm gonna be where you
are i'm not gonna get there how you get
there
i'm not going in the front door i'm
probably not gonna be invited but i'm
gonna be exactly where you're gonna
[ __ ] be
so these feet took me to europe and i
got to spend a month in europe playing
soccer getting our ass
kicked get the [ __ ] out of here what
what age were you when you were 16.
and i didn't one of my regrets in life
is i did not smoke weed then
so when we were in amsterdam we and all
the other kids
not all of them but half of them were
smoking it i wish i would have [ __ ]
smoked it but you went to amsterdam i
went to the bulldogs and everything
yeah yeah but i didn't at 16. what us
you were so good at soccer they they
sent you to europe and paid for this
[ __ ]
well we had to do some of it was paid
for and we had to do a little
fundraising i don't remember how much
but we had to like
yeah whatever we could to get um
that money and then your meals were
included and transportation and all that
[ __ ]
i've never heard this before from you
yeah that is [ __ ] awesome
we landed in uh we started in rotterdam
holland
and then we went to germany denmark
belgium um scotland
uh and england now not london but
england outskirts of uh
[ __ ] even if you got your ass how fun
yeah it was the first time i've seen
topless well
we call them topless beaches but they're
just beaches over there and
we were in belgium and um there was this
billiards game that we didn't know what
it was but we were playing it like it
was eight ball
you know regular pool but it wasn't and
this guy comes back and we've been
playing for like an hour and he's like
you're not paying for these games like
what are you talking shits
he's like that's not what this game is
and we're like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about so he kicks us
out he keeps on the beat yeah and um
there's these hot belgium uh belgian
girls
playing [ __ ] badminton and their
titties are all bouncing and stuff and
we're like hey do you mind if we play
with you
like no so it's like three of them and
three of us we're 16.
and we are hitting these birdies up as
high as we can so they lead with that so
they have to talk
[Laughter]
and we are like oh my gosh
what movie script did you just take
right now that sounds like a [ __ ]
corey feldman movie it was awesome and
we drank you know and over there they
don't so we
the 16's so much
so much we found a bar where this guy
collected hats and we would just give
him hats and he would give us
jacked in listen we'd be on we'd be
getting our ass kicked okay you would
run by somebody on our team and you
would just smell jack daniels i'm like
god no wonder we're getting killed over
here
yeah we thought we were the [ __ ] when i
said you ran the streets you should have
said no but i wouldn't
i ran it got [ __ ] paced i
um the first game we come
right down the field and we score right
away and we think we're the sh
we're like we are going to walk all over
these [ __ ] ki
hey america team coming in listen 30
days
we didn't win one game we didn't win one
[ __ ] game did you guys score at least
[ __ ] yeah we scored but we
didn't win one [ __ ] game at all
we played in it was called the thistle
cup i believe in scotland
it was called the dana cup in denmark
like there were people doing so much
we had a kid on the team that stole like
the denmark flag
like imagine somebody stealing our
united states flag that's a big ass
they were running after him through town
and [ __ ] he was leaving
sidewalk sale stuff out our the kids on
our team would grab
[ __ ] and ass you need to write this out
you know so that story alone is [ __ ]
insane it was nuts and and that's the
first time
ever because i've never was a never kid
were you a shoplifter
or anything no no my mom said you go to
hell i never shopped like so i never
got to europe on day 26 seven
our money's gone we have nothing left
and we're now
in edinburgh and we're um you know the
castles are all here we're eating in a
pizza hut because we figured out in this
pizza hut
that we could sit right in the back by
the exit door and we could
run out and we're stealing socks and it
just
it started to get way too good to
everybody and
like we're stealing dumpsters aprons
aprons with the little dick that comes
out with a bottle opener on it
people can feel whatever they can dumb
[ __ ] the americans came through to steal
and lose
steal and lose and lose yeah you're
right we didn't lose we lost
and um it was when he's when the guy
stole the
the country's flag uh we were sprinting
you know
it's fields of 10 maybe and
everyone's playing from around the world
and we're sprint interrupting these
games
there's people in the audience there's
on the we're running through the games
and there's like a field of just 10 of
them here like you ever see those big
basketball
tournaments but it's soccer fields and
it's over there and we are interrupting
they're blowing the whistle we are just
sprinting through trying to get away
from the [ __ ] police and [ __ ]
the cops chased you through the hmm what
an example when we got lost
and but we had to you know he threw the
flag uh put it somewhere and
we took off so once they saw that they
backed off of us and we just got the
[ __ ] out of there and got on a bus and
got out this needs to be a movie
that's just yeah that was amazing then
amsterdam i went to the red light
district i was 16. oh
[ __ ] but you didn't smoke weed i didn't
smoke weed but i saw
the prostitutes waving us in the window
so we all went and saw a live
sex show whoa and uh 16 at 16
and i remember seeing a girl stick a
candle on her [ __ ] and light it and
just think
oh my god
like we're all looking at each other
like what
sixteen bro we couldn't get over it stop
saying we saw
um was it a banana the girl [ __ ]
herself with a banana and then
peeled it and some dude got out of the
audience and ate the banana
like um then it was a live
sex show the guy [ __ ] the girl on
stage and i never i swear to god this is
true a guy on our team
a guy on our team was would tickle his
[ __ ]
get out of here and he would keep
kicking back like this and then they
then they kicked us out after that
you put your fingers like
what are you [ __ ] sick
yo they didn't know how old anyone was
they didn't card us at bars they didn't
card anything
are you [ __ ] kidding me yes that was
like touching the guys guys
he kept touching his foot tickling his
foot oh you said
no
get the [ __ ] off me god damn it oh [ __ ]
yeah that was
that was the red light district for you
guys
and i wanted to i know we went to the
bulldog and i remember them pulling the
drawer with the little nickel and dime
bags and some
people on our team definitely uh part
took but i just drank
and then there was some neighbor or some
local
excuse me that that grew his own and was
like come on with me and
remember we're 16 so now you're an adult
taking a minor anyway and we're like
don't get in this guy's car and the guy
on our team this guy on our team is
going to hit and
getting in the car to go to this guy's
house yes
to uh it was to uh get wheat and he
comes back
that's what i'm saying i regret it to
this day because he came back with a we
first of all we thought he was dead and
yeah you know commencement
he came back with a bag of weed that was
just
beautiful like this big really and i was
like whoa
and from the time i was 16 until i got
here again
and saw you know beautiful weed i didn't
see weed like that again
it was all we call it in baltimore we
call it practice weed
that's what we usually get practice
weeds seeds and sticks
oh practice all dry next time when you
get practice for real weed
marty told me the east coast is scarce
out there for the week it's tough
it's tough damn that story i'm just
gonna say was an adventure
i loved it i've never heard that before
yeah
leave that out i think i think you
should i think you should do something
with that i gotta be honest
for everybody else i could see their
faces that was [ __ ] incredible
that was an adventure thank you for that
thank you dude
you did your research no oh i have uh
something else coming up
great here we go i have to know
from a perspective of a fan watching
this
who the [ __ ] came up with cut man what
where
where did you guys go hey let's do these
voices no i'm gonna
i'm gonna stick with i'm gonna stick
with this one i can tell you exactly
i can tell you it's fun i would love to
talk about that please
afterward please watch the guys cut man
on youtube is [ __ ] amazing
so um i am a
especially back then but i am a big
boxing fan and and tom segorra
is too and you know we came up at the
same time and
and one of the things that really
attracted me to tom's comedies were very
much
alike in the sense that we love social
inappropriateness we like when people
are yelling at their kids in the store
like that [ __ ] makes us laugh
you know we like to cause a disturbance
we like to yell and be loud and
um i was watching
um i had this character i always did
called harvell jenkins i just had it and
harvell
is uh an ode to this black guy that
worked at ups when i worked there shout
out to ups baltimore hub primary one joe
avenue
and his name was harvell and i just
loved the name harvard i'd never heard
of it anywhere of course i moved here
and it's there's a harvell's and like
[ __ ]
santa monica and long beach and i had
never heard of harvell before
and jenkins there it is and jenkins this
harvell jenkins on the right and teddy
loons on the left um
and we jenkins was an owed to richard
pryor
when he's doing um the the wino and he's
like you did a little jenkins boy ain't
ya
you know so i took harvell and my comedy
hero
and put harvell jenkins together and tom
would do this character that was just
the same like he would yell and scream
and [ __ ] and he came up with the name
teddy loons so one night
i'm just high and i'm watching tv and
i'm looking for something and i see this
thing called
year of the bull and i think it's a
running of the bulls thing so i flip to
it
and what year the bull is is a
documentary on these high school
um or excuse me junior no high school
football programs
in like south florida and it's gangster
these coaches there it is these coaches
beat these kids and
punch these kids i mean they go this is
high school football
on these kids and it's so inappropriate
that
i'd always do what i do when i see
inappropriate [ __ ] i started dying
laughing like this is outrageous so
i send this thing to tom and i'm like
tom
you have to watch this the mentality
these coaches have with these kids
is the mentality that harvale and teddy
need to have
with their fight stable and um that's
what we did
so we took these two characters and we
wanted the dumbest tag
line that we would be yelling like
what's he got in the trunk spare tire
like we come up with these dumb
dumb names and we have this guy who's
we're almost
killing um and we train him to be our
fighter and all of our fighters
up to this point have sucked they've
been sanctioned but this guy's got
something
and tom's a a ridiculous trainer
uh and i'm a ridiculous cut man and
the things yeah that's one of my
favorite
that's out in front of my buddy's house
there was a bulldozer sitting there we
were shooting something like a tom let's
go
oh my god and we just sat in front of
that boat
so uh we keep talking about bringing it
back and doing something so anyway
i'm so glad you let me talk about this
so please keep yeah
um these are the two characters we've
created
and i just always thought the cut man
was so interesting there's this guy
that's
in floyd mayweather's corner that didn't
get past the seventh grade and he's
handling
the greatest fighter arguably in the
history of boxing really
millions and millions of dollars these
guys don't have any medical
degrees nothing they're just guys that
are taking end swells
and ice packs and [ __ ] and and cotton
swabs and and vaseline you know they
don't know anything
so um
they were always characters you know the
pins on the hat or the rings or the
whatever it was always
something they don't have to be doctors
at all there's no medical degree
required at all to stop a cut or
bleeding or anything
so i never thought about that ever my
methods are completely unorthodox and
tom's methods as a trainer on orthodox
and together
we're this team so uh we we decided to
train this this white fighter
and um his name's kenny spare tire
sparrow
and uh it's the most high are you
intimidating
to come up with these names man i'm
sorry you were smoking balls in the
garage
and you thought we thought was that
weakest [ __ ] we could come up with
so uh kenny spare tire sparrow
is our fighter and then we see a buddy
of ours mickey briggs a black guy up
there
all we do is see him working out on a
heavy bag that is it
and based off of him hitting a heavy bag
we fire
can he spare a tire sparrow get rid of
his ass and we dump
everything we have into um
the cold river killer that's his name
and then we realize in the middle of the
[ __ ] bout that he's never fought
he doesn't know what he's doing and all
hell breaks loose
you [ __ ] jesus christ
who filmed this did you guys film each
other no he did not a friend
of ours john john migdal john robert
migdal
directed this um and uh we had two guys
actually
shoot it and uh kevin was one i wish i
could remember their names
this is so long ago interview cutaways
that just
make it so much better yeah it's really
well done and john edited it too
and you know we're using vibrators on
his face right there we're just doing
all kinds of [ __ ] to get him out there
he just looked good and we based
everything on not a heavy bag workout
and there we are talking about how we
get suspended and everything and
yeah this was this was what 2006. oh wow
oh that's what i'm saying this is 15
years ago hey man bring that [ __ ] and we
put stop snitching productions in there
you know that's where that's where
that's where it started in baltimore
it's if you go to the top of it it says
stop snitching productions presents
that's baltimore [ __ ] that started watch
i think it says it
stop now i'm just getting my [ __ ] ready
and
you know especially right now this is
the time to do it mm-hmm
you need to bring that back an
association with stops in the ship
reduction i didn't catch that
and so that right there is uh that's a
five-wheel stand a friend of mine that
works at the medical field he gave me
that
and i went to a goodwill store we
outfitted the whole our outfits from a
goodwill store i had wigs
uh we went and put all this [ __ ]
together and uh
we're who let you do this in their
boxing ring so they're jimmy
this is this is what you talk about
people in boxing so
in long beach these guys had a boxing
gym and they let us not only did they
let us come in we had a crew of
i don't know maybe 15 people yeah and uh
maybe more and they let us take their
goddamn gym
and they left and they trusted us for a
saturday and a sunday to lock up and
everything i'm telling you i'm not even
lying about them yeah we paid them a
little bit
like and they were like you can have the
[ __ ] gym and we were like we'll put
you in here and [ __ ]
so like all their [ __ ] that's all this
is we didn't dress this gym at all
yeah you just walked in it's like yeah
lock up and they yeah
they did what could we couldn't believe
we're like what like we didn't even want
that responsibility like no one's gonna
come back
like now you got it so yeah we got to do
this there
um and john directed it and um
it just i had to bring it up man it's
it's one of my absolute
favorite projects i've ever done that's
showing my girlfriend the other day so
much fun so we got lucky and
we ended up selling it we shot it as a
pilot and then we ended up selling it to
comedy central back in the day had this
thing called adam tv
and we that's the reason it's broken up
into three-minute episodes it originally
was just a one-piece
22-minute pilot but they wanted to buy
it back
then because they actually were ahead of
the game where they wanted short form
content
and they took this and cut it up into
episodes
so there's ten little excuse me episodes
that are a few minutes long it's
fun [ __ ] yeah guys if you have time
after this please
please go watch that just put in cut man
um and and go watch nine inches have you
seen nine inches
i wanna i absolutely want to promote
nine inches because nine inches is
another thing tom segura and i did
together that's got quite a few views
and it's something we started that was
based off of there it is
it's based off of uh look it's got two
million views it's almost eight minutes
long
and it is based on a true story one of
your true stories no we found
we tom and i used to um send each other
true stories all the time back in the
day he'd be like look you're from that
[ __ ] baltimore look at this story
like you're from
ratness florida look at this but then
over time we would see like look at this
[ __ ] in georgia look at this [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] and [ __ ] wyoming so
we couldn't believe the crazy stories
and there was this one in particular
about this these two men
who got into an argument um over james
brown's height and it ended up in them
both shooting each other
real life story real life story and this
what we did was we created the back
story to the truth
we don't know because the news never
tells you we hear
the backstory of the newsline these two
men were in an argument and exchanged
gunfire over james brown's heights so we
made up what we think happened to lead
up to that true story of
two men exchange gunfire and an argument
over james brown's height
and it's called nine inches and i'm not
going to tell you why you have to watch
it to
understand why it's called nine inches
real quick since you did this
i feel like you know how tall is james
brown i feel like he's a little he's
five
six yeah that's about what i was
thinking it doesn't seem like a big guy
get the [ __ ] out but you got it
i'm thinking i mean this guy
no all right that i'll watch that after
i'll watch that don't ruin it please
all right well i am [ __ ] high
how did that sativa work fantastic that
was very yeah i smoked a shitload of
these
i can't wait till it's more normalized
and people are doing it like it's a
glass of wine on the table
or a beer or a whiskey on the table or
even a water goddamn it
that's gonna be a long time i think yeah
we'll see um but yeah thank you so much
for coming out here thank you for having
me on dude i appreciate you doing some
interesting [ __ ] i like the [ __ ] you
dug up you never know what somebody's
gonna dig up
i i wanna i wish i could dig up the
[ __ ] soccer europe story
what a story yeah i don't have that
anywhere on
anything i i've look i really like what
you do with the sit down and talk the
camera and do story time and i really
want to do
something like that because i have so
many of these damn stories and you're
such a good storyteller that's not even
something i would think people would
want to hear
what you just said reminds me of one of
those movies on netflix that you don't
think is going to be good and you like
that movie you ever seen sex drive
uh-uh that's a [ __ ] hilarious movie
but it looks stupid as [ __ ]
watch it that that's a movie to me that
made me
internally just imagine all this [ __ ]
happening and that's [ __ ] awesome
if i was 16 and that was happening to me
you know what i was doing 16.
[ __ ] nothing doing coke and [ __ ]
missing class that's all i was doing man
oh there it is okay
that's a good one man all right i'll
check it out but um yeah you should do
that that that's that's uh
something you would be i mean obviously
you'd be good at it
it's it's more intimate i feel i know
this is cool this is great
but being one on one you're by yourself
just look it's
give it a try it's different it makes
you feel like you can you can think more
because there's nothing else there yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
but you i mean you're on stage with a
bunch of people i've never done that
that's scary as [ __ ] to me
oh i miss that so much oh see you're on
that
it's a whole different thing for you so
i think mentally ill yes there's
something wrong with anybody that wants
to do that
no that's awesome no there's something
wrong with the human being that wants to
get up in front of an audience
of strangers and try to make them laugh
for an hour yes
you're not stable that's not normal
it might be great and it might help
people but it's not normal to want to do
that you know there's some trauma that
has come
to make you want to do that yeah but
when people like when i tell stories of
stuff that happened to me as a kid when
people tell me how horrible it is i
think
damn it kind of was [ __ ] i don't think
about it and you're so used to it
because it's normal
that's right it's exactly so when i see
these stories until it's not normal yeah
man sometimes you're hungry what the
[ __ ] are you trying to say
it's just it's cool to see your show
some of these comedians are saying [ __ ]
i've never heard before
the people we have on there you would
never ever expect
the type of [ __ ] that they talk about be
so open joe coy
crying about his stepfather and his real
father
and like how great they were especially
he's a father now
jeremiah uh good ones
tommy lee came on and shared some funny
[ __ ] i can't even get over tommy lee was
on my [ __ ] show yes
that's the other thing i love doing you
can hear it in your voice you can
definitely hear it
when you introduced him
i'll never get over any of this stuff
doing these shows i love it like
this definitely keeps me sane for sure
it's an outlet yeah
and but it's also the people i'm doing
shows with and who come on they're good
people
with good you know good intentions are
just good they're
quality people who've been through a lot
of [ __ ] and they have a
you know again going back to comedians
they can shine a comedic light
on on trauma and it's what i need yeah
you know it makes me feel comfortable
it's almost like i really love the blues
i love the blues because that's it i
love someone who can take this
pain and this suffering and this trauma
and spin it into an
artistic way that talks back to me that
makes me feel good about that
so there's moments in blues where i
laugh out loud like when bb king says
nobody loves me but my mother and she
might be jiving too
i mean that makes me laugh out loud
that's a personal thing to you though
yes
very totally understand what you're
saying like yeah yeah gotcha
so yeah yeah well no that's something i
i i didn't expect but i it's so [ __ ]
cool to see on your podcast it's
please come back again oh of course of
course yes anytime
but i just want to tell everybody in the
audience check it out the honeydew
podcast it's like therapy session i feel
but in a good way yeah it's not like
everyone's breaking it's
it makes you feel good about you exactly
oh he's been through some
[ __ ] too and he laughed about it that's
how i feel that's right
um thank you so much that was a long
thanks for coming out we talked for 10
more minutes but
thank you so much for coming yeah thank
you for having me appreciate you guys
check it out uh ryan stickler all
all social media yeah brian sickle on
all social media honeydew
spotify honeydew everywhere you get
podcasts
honey do with you all that's the patreon
nice check that out all the links will
be in the description
uh youtube spotify our website thanks
for coming out i
appreciate me brother thank you guys
thank you so much for hanging out that
was uh
that was fun i am f i need to stop
smoking so much damn weed on here i am
high [ __ ]
thank you guys so much for watching this
has been another episode of the dope as
usual podcast
thank you guys and again ryan sinkler
have a dope ass day
[Music]
[Laughter]
hello
ready
[Laughter]
i just feel like that [ __ ]
[ __ ] i feel like
[ __ ] on drugs
we juice and juice diet jesus christ
that's the california diet right there
you ready all right
oh man i wish i didn't look so [ __ ]
high for this pro bowl
all right
damn it all right here we go i just
feel like i'm just a big [ __ ] cheese
and smile right now it's not good
all right okay
damn it
let's do it
right there [ __ ]
there we go
damn it marty here we go thank you guys
so much for watching another episode of
dope you
see
thank you guys so much again [ __ ] you
thank you guys so much for watching
another episode of the dope as usual
podcast
if you didn't know already we started a
patreon so we started a patreon
the youtube vid [ __ ] you
there we go what's up guys
thank you again so much for watching
another episode of the dope as usual
podcast
if you didn't know already we just
started a patreon for everyone that
signed up thank you so much
if not if you haven't and if you want to
click the link in the description below
the video
thank you guys so much for the support
also we have this youtube channel
obviously the one you're watching right
now but we also have a dope as usual
podcast clips
go ahead and follow that that's in the
description also and if you guys didn't
know we're live on
apple spotify and all the streaming
platforms you can let's do a podcast
we're on there then we'll cut right
there and then i'm gonna say bye because
i ran out of [ __ ] breath
i was trying not to [ __ ] up and i did it
i did it
all right here we go again thank you so
much for watching another episode of the
dope
[ __ ] you again thank you so much for
watching another episode until next time
i'm dobasiola
have a dope ass day
[Music]
perfect
[Music]